[Musique]
robin
oui
bah
le
bon allez
ah ah
[Musique]
mais
on n'est pas là pour se faire engueuler
on est là pour voir le défilé
on n'est pas là pour se faire assommer
on est venus pour voir le défier on est
là pour voir lunettes noires pour nuit
blanche le défilé de stars du samedi
soir bonsoir à lui tout fastoche
juliette binoche juliette cinoche mais
jamais jamais juliette téloche quatre
ans qu'on n'avait pas vu dans lunettes
c'est juliette et c'est chouette il y
avait jean hindriks il y à barbara
hendricks vois simone annexes moi je
suis très nona à mirande observations
deuxième explication troisième
satisfaction au blind test hattrick
bruel et évangile selon compile les
toons période brian jones après rocky a
prêché parti voici dolphy interview
signalement du punisher killer je suis
ou des critiques dominic sonic c'est
super ce n'était en plus c'est exclu
attention monument historique selby
interview l'auteur de l'aspect petit
roman culte on exulte la fureur de lire
continue avec les onze livres les plus
cultes comme un banal voici beautiful sa
hausse le maire basiques de la pop music
vers d'honneur pour ses pots de fleurs
complètement historique pour ses
céramiques jean-pierre raynaud interview
pinceau définitif sur l'alternative pas
de méprise et indesit à aux anti stress
s express la house music vers mystique
mais pas de panique télévision création
télévision montrent le sont pour l'heure
dix ans du samedi soir bonsoir vous êtes
sûr lunettes noires pour nuits blanches
l'émission qui déclenche
c'est là le rayon des arçons de la
blague chanson cette nana là c'est un
gros x none à son don mais là messieurs
son don c'est de changer de son à chaque
nouveau microsillon plus de commercial
pour elle le principal c'est
l'expérimental
[Musique]
maintenant
quittant
[Musique]
donner d'espoir
c'est tout
enfin
le matin
[Musique]
mais
m
ce qu elle ne lésine pas
à me connaître
[Musique]
mais
qui
est mal
donner d'espoir
mennucci
donc c'est tout moment
oui mais août
au matin
oui mais où
tél
oui
dgo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
décidé de garder
une
dynamique du t1
est jeune elle m'a plu ce sens mérite ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
il est en outre
doté suis pas là
[Musique]
quand et où
oui mais nous
parce que j'aime
oui mais non
[Musique]
tél
c'était nona hendryx momie ou fly
extrait de 133 skin dériveur le 6
novembre au new morning marre de cette
nana là voici patrick bruel pas besoin
de courte échelle au blind test un des
best avant ça envoie bruel mois miel que
d'hab et c'est plutôt mieux patrick
bruel bonsoir on était géo donc la
méditerranée
oscar qu'a dit a choisi pour le coup de
sirocco il conte de fées a commencé tu
faisais quoi au club méditerranée
annonce arkadina pas choisir en voyant
que la méditerranée j'ai choisi sur un
casting non il m'a choisi sur une petite
annonce dans france soir j'étais au
lycée j'ai eu une petite annonce
on m'a mis une petite annonce ulm
présenté à l'audition l'addition s'est
bien passé j'ai tourné le film pourquoi
tu as gagné parce que tu avais l'accent
pieds noirs non je suis allé à
l'audition parce que je pouvais prendre
action pieds noirs j'ai gagné parce que
j'ai beaucoup de chance que je suis
arrivé dans une salle où il y avait 80
personnes il était 4 heures d'après midi
ce pétard je n'ai pas très envie de
rester donc je suis resté debout ouais
je me suis resté loyal frères d'arcadie
qui entre dans la salle qui m'a regardé
de loin comme j'étais de fou il m'a vu
et à feytiat paulo paulo creusot on
cherche un polo venez donc ils ont fait
lire ça fait marrer ça ressemblait un
peu à peu à la famille ben moussa après
tu as eu peur de devenir le pied noir de
service c'est ça tu t'es dit si je
continue à faire des rôles de pieds
noirs ça va être infernale non moi je
voulais bien faire des rôles de
figurants le penser qu'on proposait pas
de trucs très bien le deuxième rang de
12e j vous mets proposés après après le
tir au co ça s'appelait rodriguez au
pays des merguez priori je me suis barré
nuit là je me suis barré new york
pendant un an et puis c'est passé plein
de choses j'ai fait plein de rencontres
ont été levés par ta mère en arrivant de
tlemcen tulle aime ta mère beaucoup de
pays qui lui demandait toujours conseil
c'est vrai pourquoi
parce qu'elle n'a jamais donné de
mauvais ouais
mais retraite a dit nous les juifs on
demande toujours conseil à nos mamans
pourquoi cela tu crois que j'ai mise à
moi ouais non c gepa dit nous les juifs
ont dit non c'est ou dans un journal
allait montre moi quand je les ai pas là
je sais pourquoi tu crois que c'est
différent des autres tu crois absolument
pas différent des autres
non je sais pas on dit qu'elles ont dit
que les orientaux ont le sens de la
famille kate ont péri développe web les
latins jeudi dans le même article
derrière teddy qui touche toujours ton
étoile de david et que les gens croient
que tu le crac
je crois que je me gratte ouais ça c'est
très vrai bon c'est vrai ça c'est une
presse un porte bonheur pour toi
tu inquiet en ce moment quand tu lis
dans globe des histoires d'autant lara
ou quand il voit le succès de le pen
je suis inquiet
oui je suis très inquiet très inquiet
autant lara avait envoyé en janvier une
photo là on a fait une petite photo
avec le bleu noir
[Musique]
gérard darmon francis huster
mais tu t'es fait un petit peu richard
berry vous mettez la à la bar mitzvah du
film du fils de lelouch dont étaient
tous avec la kippa comme ça puis tiens
si on nourrit la photo du temps la race
du plaisir ah bon mais on en vit la
famille alors on a vu des réactions on
n'a pas encore on va voir
on sait pas si elle est arrivée il fait
quoi concrètement à part lui envoyer des
photos tu milites dans un
dans un mouvement tu
ouais je crois que je me tous les jours
quand ta vie quotidienne ma vie
quotidienne enfin des quelque 66
m'appelle j'essaye donc présent ces
pages comment par exemple
c'est à dire je sais pas aujourd'hui
t'as fait quoi par exemple je sois
michon ne volera 6 aujourd'hui j'ai
tourné mon clip tout ajournement
jeu ça se passe comment ça se passe
donc ça se passe cassisi jeu si je tombe
sur quelqu'un à qui nous attend que tu
me demandes exactement je te demande à
part envoyé des photos autant-lara ce
que tu fais concrètement contre le
racisme dans ta vie quotidienne
c 'est pas
j'ai pas désarçonner ses pages pas quoi
dire concrètement oui concrètement jeu
je me dis je vais à dire j'avais à des
meetings je vais ad je parle je parle
aux gens je parlais des jeunes que je
crois je parle à mes frères
c'est vrai concrètement je veux pas je
descends pas dans ma rue en disant tiens
aujourd'hui concrètement je vais battre
au racisme il vient ici je suis sur un
quai de gare et que je vois
pai avait le jura on algérien devant moi
à la gare à monter dans un train il
mentait quand il est monté dans la
grande première de type le nom et ses
papiers
j'ai regardé chef de gare il m'a regardé
je les regarde et il m'a regardé j'ai
regardé et il est passé il ya moins de 7
à pied j'étais pas j enfin bon un peu
goutte d'eau tu es rapport avec le
métier sont plutôt bons noms qui
fêterait métier combien
je voyais beaucoup à un moment que ça
brille et départ normal qui est rare
dans ce métier tu es content ça bride
pas envie était henri plein de choses
alors j'ai invité à des soirées tivat
mtd première qui va avec qui ses copains
dans le métier dans mon métier j'ai très
peu vincent lindon
en contrepoint
il a mangé après ce verdict
ses messes
bono garcin lecteurs j'adore qui
d'ailleurs tiens je vous tous les soirs
en ce moment aux bouffes-parisiens wesh
promo parce que c'est bien promotionner
parce que personne n'y a pas beaucoup de
gens qui y vont c'est un spectacle
génial c'est tous les soirs à 18h30 au
pour vous pharisiens et je trouve que
c'est bien d'aller voir bruno dire 150
auteurs et
d'ailleurs il avait fait de textes avec
une arme
et son spectacle formidable tout cas
c'est une belle réflexion sont plaints
de secours
voilà la promo la du disque ça te fait
chier la promo ça dépend comment les
fenêtres ce n'est pas comment c'est fait
pis elle pense que tu défends
j'aime bien le disque
donc allez chanter la chanson ça me gêne
pas vous conseille un tournant ce disque
aussi j'espère ni religion le blind test
crois que ça va être une corvée ou non
sa couette une fois ça me fait marrer
mais je pense qu'on va lui et à mort
j'espère qu'on va le pousser j'espère
les nazis non on va pas le coincer c'est
pas très dur le premier
[Musique]
bravo
ouais
c'est ça la maison alors ils meurent
convert savoir si ça les maisons le
latéral
c'est tout
bush
[Musique]
je sens qu'on a eu et attendait
qui
je l'aide on peut le bulletin
[Musique]
attends j'adore ça c'est au monde
guitariste pianiste eric clapton comme
la france la
france ndlr est maintenant on passe au
grand salon
à william sheller bravo bravo
aux producteurs par
diana maronite lanaro qui vient de
produire les deux derniers albums de
chainel et de donner des milliers de
données nougaro ouais c'est un mec
formidable parce que qu'est-ce qu'un bon
producteur non non c'est pas gentil hein
un type pour affecter qui en studio tu
donnes beaucoup quand un bon metteur en
scène
tu ne reconnais pas là trop sarira mot
bravo c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'ils
visitent eu les affaires et ils voient
tout chanson tu vois je suis planté
non c'est juste assez ralenti à type
vachement sympa j il fallait me bats
j'aime pas ouais y'a pas de dire que
comme tout le monde j'aime pas tout le
monde ment qui t'aiment pas mais je
crois que c'est pas la peine de faire un
appel aux gens pour rien par contre se
fâcher avec quelqu'un s'il tout de suite
peut quitter envie de pêcher là
où j'étais bien parti pour passer avec
toi tu m'avais trop gonflé
je reconnais l'intro salah sur un mon
meilleur copain gérard presgurvic bravo
gérard je vais rencontrer à new york en
1979 chercher un piano pour
jouer ces chansons pour travailler moi
j'étais électronique en tout cas d un
piège il est venu il a joué à quoi ça
tient il a joué j'ai entendu je les
tiens voilà quelqu'un qui
qui dit des choses que j'ai envie de
dire puisqu'il était mieux que moi alors
travaillons ensemble
on a chanté brel mariano
c'était pas trop sur la chaîne télé
policière
le très court this way sa moyenne des
six mois par contre comme jusqu'à un peu
moins bien bah je sais pas mon métier je
ne sais pas vraiment un métier
c'est plus dur
si on pouvait lui et ça serait sympa là
je veux bien jouer attendez le plaisir
d'évoluer mais ce qu'ils aiment aller
mais c'est quand même mais ces mêmes
gens ce qui est arrivé
je sache on
obtient station s'est fait huer pour de
vrai alors attendez c'est pas vrai lui
subi c'est pas ta grande époque mais
c'est le mec qui chante mais si c'est le
mec qui chante le nord ah si ça
je crois que je suis qui chante oh mon
bateau la
whey c'est pas dans les moeurs et nos
cités
destiné à évaluer nazario moreno lui a
coûté la toute nouvelle chanson the way
the way lunettes
ya déjà dix ans ils étaient sur les
rangs à 24 ans l'indépendant devient
prétendants solitaire leur coeur est
alors comme dirait jean éric perrin de
cette solitude qui fait la force ouais
si dominic sonic clip très hip hop
[Musique]
tu as su les
hier
m
elle
et
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
temps
après
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
entre stone ses stooges c'était dominic
sonic when my tears and gold qui fait
jugnot le pour 30000 ball par joe pinto
maria brava grands moments de téloche
voici maintenant juliette binoche
l'actrice se fait lectrices spécial
lecture de celle qui dure comme à la
première nuit les écrivains ce soir au
couvent des cordeliers dans le cadre de
la fureur de lire auteur acteur chanteur
fait l'événement en ce moment très recul
tuera littérateurs
mardi matin 9h30
hier soir en allant chez lui j'étais
plein d'une aimable longueur printanière
et tandis que désire en sa présence je
[__] et rêveusement sur la salle de
l'airé strates
je me senti soudain caressé par une
sieste brise de printemps et je pensais
tout à coup
cela aussi c'est bon
pourquoi ne connaîtront pas une
véritable l'ivresse amoureuse tendre et
profonde au contact du printemps ou de
tous les êtres on peut aussi se lier
d'amitié avec un hiver avec une ville ou
un pays
je me souviens dû être rouge de mon
adolescence
j'avais une liaison toute particulière
avec cet arbre
certains soirs prise d'un désir soudain
de le voir
je faisais une demi-heure des
bicyclettes pour lui rendre visite et je
tournais autour de lui et poti zay par
son regard rouge sang
ouais pourquoi ne vivrai ton pas un
amour avec un printemps
et la caresse de cet air printanier
était si tendre si enveloppante que
celle de mama spleen fussent les siennes
nous paraissait gosset en comparaison
à découvert comment ce bouquin
j'ai découvert je marchais dans les rues
peel ça dimanche et j'ai trouvé une
librairie ouvert plus est
on peut chercher des bouquins comme ça
pour lire pour découvrir quelque chose
mais vous et puis
je suis tombé dessus j'ai aimé le titre
une vie bouleversée
et puis j'ai senti qu'il y avait quelque
chose dans ce livre je vais rien lui on
n'aime pas
la couverture n'est rien mais je sentais
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui avait
dans ce bouquin qui m'attirait nous
étions là deux bonnes heures mercredi
matin tout un groupe réunis dans les
locaux de la gestapo
et les événements de nos vies étaient à
cet instant précis exactement les mêmes
nous étions tous dans la même pièce les
interrogateurs retrancher derrière leur
bureau et les interroger ce qui
distinguait toutes ces vies entre elles
c'était l'attitude intérieur de chacun
l'oeil et est immédiatement attiré par
un jeune homme qui faisait les cent pas
l'air mécontent et ne cherche nullement
à dissimuler ce mécontentement traquer
et tourmenté
tous les prétextes étaient bons pour
abrutir de crise et malheureux juifs pas
de mains dans les poches etc nous
paraissait plus à plaindre que ceux qui
l'apostrophé ainsi et ces derniers de
l'été d'ailleurs que dans la mesure où
ils avaient peur
quand ce fut mon tour de passer à son
bureau il me lança enregis ans mais
qu'est ce que vous pouvez bien prouver
de risible ici
j'avais envie de répondre à part avoue
rien
mais des considérations diplomatiques me
firent jugé préférable de ravaler cette
réplique nous n'arrêtait pas de rire au
gîte il encore mois d'inventaire montner
le plus innocent je me rends pas du tout
content c'est mon expression habituel et
lui fait pas idiote et sortez
immédiatement
le tout assorti d'une limite qui
signifiait
on se retrouvera
c'était probablement le moment
psychologique aux j'aurais dû mourir de
frayeur mais j'ai tout de suite percer à
jour son truc
c'est un peu comparable journal d'anne
frank mais c'est plus c'est moins naïve
parce que les plus âgés peut-être well
as 27 ans
disons que l'on sent au cours de ce
livre la maturation fall
elle prend conscience de ce que la vie
et
la force qu'elle doit y mettre dans sa
vie et puis ne reste plus que quelques
quelques années le seuil est très clair
très clair en m mais parvient pas à lire
les gens non non c'était les hommes et
plus ou moins riches et dames les
allemands c'est un truisme total au
milieu d'une tourmente et d'un et juste
avant les clans
s'étonnant qu'un témoignage et elle est
morte à auschwitz d'ailleurs en 43
si vous avez ça pour la fureur de lire
j'ai vu ça par amour pour ce qu'ils sont
et quand tu lis un scénario s'est
tue laborde comme un livre qui la borde
comment quand on te propose un scénario
j'en ai très peu d'abord parce que je
suis un peu paresseux
eux
mon agent ma jambe et une confiance du
lot la wii est non seulement de
confiance
sa peur qu'un jour il laisse passer un
truc exceptionnel
non maman parce que
des fois j'ai des contres des contacts
des metteurs en scène et puis
en fait ça ne prend plus de rencontres
et metteur en scène peut le dire son
scénario en fonction la rencontre que je
fais je
décide ou pas de lire le scénario mais
jamais je n'ai pas un scénario avant de
rencontrer quelqu'un pour moi c'est
absurde tu as eu une vie de 15 ans
non
la tournée avec lui tu n'as pas lu je
lui ai dit je lui ai dit que je préfère
découvrir par moi-même que de découvrir
au travers de ce qui dit de lui
mais il se cacherait pas que les acheter
en français il n'a offert en anglais
mais dédicacé mais je peux dire ce qui
doit marquer soit le week-end a signé
il ay l'acier si me souviens bien
hessel
le singe parce que je les traiter de
singe
qui marchait commence alors sa
d'atterrir et d'assigner le singe
messinger ajouté tu veux faire le
questionnaire de proust
c'est quoi pour toi le comble de la
misère
ce serait si misérable compris qui
aurait pas de mot pour le pour le dire
l'argent quand tu étais petit je n'ai
pas d'argent conduite tu veux petit tu
me dis à quel âge j'étais en france chez
toi aidez vous avez de l'argent ou pas
ça va souffrir
non
tu aimerais vivre ou un parent paraît
paraître comme c'est beau pour quelle
faute à tuer le plus d'indulgence parle
et y est
je me force de pas trop juger vite
tu est bonne
boenisch ça dépend des goûts
l occupation préférée
occupation quelle horreur samou
ce que j'aime le plus faire pour que
j'aime ça il ya beaucoup de choses je
suis pas un
jeu
c'est quoi je chantre du genre dans ce
rapport gilles boyer adore je voyais je
l'accusé non
pour les animaux c'est tout près
des animaux ce à quoi j'ai trois shanxi
on peut être beau à la maison serait
maître qui s'ils n'étaient pas jugées de
pillage
[Musique]
wamen ah bon tu pense pas à ça tu ne dis
pas j'aurais aimé et john ware ou non
tels que les ti n'ont
pas les trucs comme ça c'est qu'on tente
de temps ça
ah ça c'est autre chose
le principal trait de caractère à ton
avis c'est quoi avant j'aurais dit l'
enthousiasme
maintenant je sais plus très bien
son principal défaut d'être dispersés
c'est pour l'intérêt qu'ils espèrent
sa fleur préférée
normalement c'est les pivoines je pense
jamais les ailiers ça fait c'est que ma
vie s'épauler
ah oui désolé ouais quand il ya beaucoup
ça me fait tourner la tête
ses auteurs préférés
auteur de livres
les hausses sauf qu'il écrit très bien
j'ai une passion pour balzac à un moment
sinon je découvre des auteurs qui me
pèse bien broad qui met nouvel amoureux
quoi d'autre
j'ai plus
le don de la nature que tu voudrais
avoir
nous sommes à aucun don du tam tam
cg oui sur des casseroles avant ça fait
des maisons et chalets camfin comment tu
aimerais mourir
on tient
ce règne
l'état présentons esprits maintenant
l'état présente mon esprit
c'est pas moi c'est pause
et à présent mon esprit
un peu de confusion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
exact
saïfi au procès mais les oiseaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre chance non
enter
non
là
à
m
furyk à
saint pierre
[Musique]
ciao ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on change de disque avec le petit stick
jean pierre rey nous pour l'interview
passons après 28 ans de pots de fleurs
et de carreaux blancs superstar de la
superstar dollars jean pierre rey 2 tu
as dit à l'école on m'avait appris à
soigner les fleurs mais pas les empêcher
de mourir je décidé d'éviter de faire de
nouvelles victimes en remplissant des
pots de fleurs et du ciment
[Applaudissements]
oui
d'abord il faut que je dise que j'ai
fait des études d'horticulture donc je
devais des jardiniers
offert du paysage des choses comme ça et
c'était le moment de la guerre d'algérie
c'était en 59 bon j'ai fait deux ans et
demi d'armé et au retour vraiment j'ai
décidé que la nature c'était terminé
pour moi alors je suis resté un an
allongé sur mon lit on m'a ali on m'a
nourri finalement je voulais absolument
plus bouger et un jour je me suis levé
au bout d'une année et j'ai descendu
précipitamment dans mon garage un peu
poussé par une forme de deux pulsions et
j'ai trouvé dans ce garage un pot de
peinture rouge un pot de fleurs et du
ciment et c'est ça le commencement j'ai
mille ciment dans le pot gelé pas en
rouge et j'ai senti à ce moment là que
j'ai été sauvé
donc j'ai commencé à revivre et j'ai
commencé à naître j'avais 23 ans j'étais
très jeune et j'avais besoin de de vivre
l'art un peu comme une aventure
romantique certainement
ce qui est peut-être plus intéressant
c'est que ça fait 28 ans que je remplis
des pots de fleurs avec du ciment et tu
mets des souvenirs sous le ciment des
fois non alors parfois je glisse c'est
un peu des bouteilles à la mer parfois
dans le ciment je mets des messages ou
au début je mettais mes poubelles je
remplissais les pots de mai détritus et
je mettais un petit mot dessus et par la
suite j'ai envoyé des messages comme ça
je fais des
certaines personnes ont peut-être cassé
leur pour un jour et on était peut-être
un peu surpris de voir quelque chose
qu'ils ont compris au pas compris
c'était ma façon de communiquer avec
l'extérieur mais c'était très instinctif
tu les a exposés ou cpo alors je les ai
exposé en allemagne à düsseldorf j'en ai
mis 400 l'un à côté de l'autre et je les
vendais le prix d'un pot de fleurs chez
le fleuriste
personnes en a acheté
et amuser un peu plus avisés à rapide ça
vaut combien aujourd'hui impôts d'impôt
à fleurs pas en rouge
ça vaut ce que le marché veut bien en
donner mais d'une façon générale 30
mille francs
en fait toujours 28 ans déjà je crois
que je le ferai encore pendant peut-être
les 25 ans qui me reste à vivre et à
fait inquiets qui est très grand qui est
la fondation cartier à jouy en josas qui
mesure trois mètres cinquante de
diamètre qui est pas en doré qui est
sous une serre oui j'en ai fait un
recouvert de feuilles d'or et j'avais
fait un projet pour l'arabie saoudite
qui n'a pas été réalisé encore et dont
la hauteur était de 30 à 40 mètres donc
de toute façon pour moi le ya plus
d'échelle pour les peaux plus les peaux
sont grands et plus et moi thérapie ici
donc il ya toujours ce rapport j'en ai
fait des tout petits qui font un
centimètre et demi que j'ai trouvée au
japon parce que les vignettes et rentrer
tôt miniature voilà et
non non ça j'ai vraiment trouvé quelque
chose de fantastique alors après il ya
eu l'histoire de la maison j'ai décidé
que
que je pouvais plus cohabiter avec le
monde extérieur et j'ai décidé de faire
une maison qui était une forme de
blockhaus et je me suis enfermé dedans
si à la celle saint cloud en ce sens et
c'est une maison qui est entièrement
recouverte c'est de le maison qui était
qui était plainte et ouais les portes
étaient blindées il y avait une
meurtrière et
j'étais très heureux a lancé un bunker
quoi c'est un mot viol et c'est au
premier degré il ya toutes ces
expressions comme ça il ya tous et
expressionnisme mais je pense que
derrière il ya aussi un terrain qu ont
défriché qu'on labour est bon
aujourd'hui j'ai plus les mêmes
fantasmes mais je reste totalement
fidèle à moi même jour dans la maison
j'habite absolument la maison je les
ferme et la dernière pour vingt années
ah bon parce que j'étais envahi par deux
cent mille personnes sont riches
derrière chaud début quand aulas voulait
montrer ta maison ils fêtaient un
autobus pour amener les gens voir sa
maison et puis après tu avais les
badauds que qui venait la voir le
dimanche quoi un peu comme j'avais
j'avais les badauds mais j'avais aussi
les chartes heures qui venaient des
états unis de ce rallye du japon est
partout parce que ça c'est le problème
des télévisions et
et des médias plus en plus on en montre
est plus fort montré alors au bout de 20
ans j'estimais que j'avais donné et j'ai
cassé le nez cassé le truc et j'ai
décidé de me donner 20 ans a lui
toujours dedans mais on n'a plus droit
de la visite et sa soul man je vais y
rentrer tout à l'heure et je le vrai en
et quand tu rentres dedans des fois tu
te dis pas que tu voudras habiter
ailleurs que non
c'est pas cher est ce que ce n'est pas
devenu un espèce de rituels une espèce
de fidélité à peut-être plus qu'à ton
image met en oeuvre et que tu préfères
réhabilité comme tout le monde dans un
appartement ou normal non je ne veux
absolument pas habité comme tout le
monde mais par contre dire que c'est
facile ça n'est pas facile
mais de toute façon moi j'ai choisi mon
destin depuis très longtemps j'ai
divorcé il ya 25 ans pour pour vivre
avec cette maison j'avais choisi déjà
j'ai décidé que je n'aurai jamais
d'enfants j'ai décidé que je vivrai seul
définitivement donc il faut que j'assume
aussi tout ça alors que je sois
prisonnier de mon image ça c'est pas
contestable je crois que toute personne
qui qui est égocentrique fonctionne avec
son avec l'entraînement de son image
mais à ce moment là il faut créer une
règle du jeu il faut il trouver son
compte il faut sentir les points d'
équilibre
et il faut avoir surtout une un très bon
équilibre psychique
ça marche ça marche ça continue à
travers travail et la céramique tu as
fait un jardin à monte carlo deux mille
mètres carrés en céramique tu rêves de
faire une cathédrale tu devais faire une
synagogue chicago je sais pas si je rêve
de faire une cathédrale jeu de la
synagogue et chicago qui voulaient bien
la faire on my absolument sais pas tu va
la faire
en fait certains projets arrivent
ne se font pas d'autres se font manger
un très beau projet sur lequel je suis
depuis huit ans et qui je pense va se
réaliser dans deux ans qui est le
recouvrement d'une des tours des
minguettes
fenêtres murs une des tours qui est mûr
et finalement qui ne servira plus jamais
et qui sera complètement occulté par les
carreaux de céramique sur les portes sur
les fenêtres et qui sera un peu la
mémoire du lieu alors ça c'est un beau
projet parce que la tour fait 50 mètres
de hauteur et il ya vraiment des gens
qui ont vécu à l'intérieur qui ont qui
ont souffert ou qui ont été heureux et
je vais travailler sur du vécu et c'est
quand même un objet qui ne sera pas un
objet rapporté c'est un objet de la
mémoire les gens qui sont à côté
connaissent cette chose et je vais
simplement venir apporter mon élément en
fait tu travailles pour les archéologues
du futur quoique ils vont déterrer des
pots de fleurs qui vont regarder ce
qu'il ya derrière tes céramique non ça
me déplaît tant que ça me déplaît pas
l'idée de me placer été très critiqué
très détesté on m'a pas pris au sérieux
parce que je crois qu'un type qui qui
fait des pots de fer toute sa vie on
ricane c'est normal et qui emploie des
carottes sanitaire qu'on trouve dans
l'est dans les toilettes et dans les
abattoirs
c'est pas très sérieux mais en fait je
fais ça depuis 28 ans je crois que dans
le domaine du travail quand un ouvrier
fait son boulot pendant pendant 28 ans
on le respecte mais voilà alors de la
même façon moi je demande que après 28
ans de remplissage de pots de fleurs et
de hêtres carrelage ombre respecte
c'était influencé partie mandrillon non
j'étais influencé je prends par personne
au début parce que c'est mon instinct
qui m'a poussé c'est ma pulsion mais
j'ai des attirances comme tout le monde
et mais je ne suis pas influencé je
crois que klein est un des plus grands
artistes de la deuxième partie du xxème
siècle c'est certainement le le pilier
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord mais ça
j'en suis convaincu
mais je peux aimer des choses très très
différente je peut m'intéresser à
l'histoire de l'art mais j'en suis pas
victime d'une allée vite bien sûr bien
sûr parce que c'est quand même une
dimension de l'absolu c'est pas d'art
qu'il s'agisse et c'est le sait le
dépassement de l'homme donc c'est
d'ailleurs le déplacement de l'homme ces
larges et maintenant spécial fureur de
lire voici 11 livres cultes de ce conte
connection ils sont tous donnent aucun
offre parce qu'il n'ya pas de mauvais
chef-d'oeuvre
last exit to brooklyn d'hubert selby
junior last exit est-il à l'amérique des
années 50 ce que l'archipel est à l'urss
des 70 voyage au bout de la nuit sur ses
lignes tout a été dit jusqu'au bout de
l'ennui le ciné n'est jamais arrivé à
l'adapter pour des images voire tardy
vos dessous du volcan malcom lowry
première version refusé deuxième
manuscrit perdu suivant incendié
quatrième un succès mexique consul
mescal le festin nu william banks
longtemps interdit désormais légendaire
le must du bouquin défense et d'un look
s'invente l'homo lavaud en petits
boutons blancs
le seigneur des anneaux tolkien avec son
voyage aux beats landes tolkien invente
l'héroïque fantaisie recommandé aux
écolos cartésien s'abstenir d'une frank
herbert roman historique classique mais
intergalactique c'est shakespeare plus
star wars adaptation ciné planté par
jodorowsky
cent ans de solitude de gabriel garcia
marquez fondation grandeur décadence du
village de macondo un produit colombien
ne permet pas une ligne belle du
seigneur d'albert cohen l'autre
événements de mai 68 le plus beau roman
d'amour de la seconde moitié du siècle
pour le lire profiter d'une longue
maladie les reins bernard frank libre
fondateur du franquisme 30 qu'il n'a
jamais été une star influence tous les
nouveaux usages introuvable pendant 20
ans un thé au sahara paul ball strip
américain à tanger lou doillon casino
ryan jones bertolucci on fait un film
avec malkovich
précis de décomposition cioran antidote
obligatoire au fondamentalisme de la fin
du siècle donc fondamental c'était un
oeuf son offre pourquoi parce qu'il n'ya
pas de mauvais chef-d'oeuvre
[Musique]
folie des teenagers il ya tout meilleurs
à l'époque il s'appelait house martin
ils ont expliqué peur de se répéter ou
parce qu'ils sont engueulés voici ce qui
en rêvent forrest maugest folie tanba
stan avec biutiful sa propre sauce et
bravo
connemara
bah
on a là
[Musique]
tous
nous sommes
tous me
[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]
banquier
bon sommeil
je veux tu
kadjo aveu que dieu ne
[Musique]
passe au cabba
un peu de tout
il
ya un an
[Musique]
et
pas de
s
alors
[Musique]
pourquoi
t
venant
oui
il sort
[Musique]
oh
c
[Musique]
des hommes
sa passion
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
faux
c'est
ça
oh la la
[Musique]
pas
c'était beautiful south t sur lunettes
malus est l'émission qui zappe tout seul
ex monsieur grace jones ex ivan drago
contre requis four wacey dolph lundgren
graines de musclor à l'écran de punisher
anti roquette anti char tu y vois si
dolphy soir tissone il est bien besoin
d'une bonne punition dolph lundgren
bruce telle cause you and
more garde bien de dieu juste combien
bien
ses balles est
battu et vidéos changelog from months in
to golf
est ouest au german mabina
dont in stockholm
16 go
à 1 to you
want to
end the way
to time you paint championnat karaté
xxx chimie technique chimie technique
chimique ni we
then you you you met grace jones un way
back
ce n'est
[Musique]
pas
de la langue de la poule didio florin
inxs
une
activité no sleep un autre
nom
[Musique]
de séparation des
films ou des colts mr grace jones
help you
mais mister et miss torn ones who knew
you are in view to care team to be with
red johnson
d'amour without
[Musique]
being made
men
cette
somme
[Musique]
why why où tout le monde
ait thousand people to play in rock
efforts to be to b ivan drago why we are
the people we choose your
[Musique]
move and
look ne parvenant
à se battre
sans
rien fait mousser the bad and we
can you tell me out d'idiot scène
stallion to hospital shooting roquefort
et les clubs
de basket
alors
si oui
stallion ask you to become stronger par
roquefort une fois de punisher de
producer qu'amène ask you to be seen
with
each aux ateliers axés petit toutou play
et le punisher affaires de toubib comme
tina
[Musique]
bachmann
c'est vrai qu'à héros d'un super héros
tu n'es pas fort au toit non tu ne
voyais pas comme si quand même non
tu n'as pas de grands devait comme
batman non on m'appelle punisher
c'est pourtant facile ne pas se tromper
[Musique]
on ne peut pas laisser les gens croire
qu'un explique traque les truands comme
du gibier depuis cinq ans et court
toujours alors
tu as décidé que tout le monde devait
mourir un espoir lors les coupables
doivent mourir avez vous peur du petit
chat le punisher c'est un truc pour
faire augmenter la vente des journaux il
n'existe pas
et
délié pas de panache heures
jason eaton aux
states
is made it is taking woodstock into gold
et
traduire devant le cirdi nos
techniques et
scénaristiques compétition oui havre qui
doivent se négocie collège parti à new
york dolphy will win de balle comme
accru à la génomique
stand
by
choice to be kirk douglas charlton
heston john wayne lancaster will you
choose to be
par isna
[Musique]
en direct de lardy scène c'était dolph
lundgren trey hardee un peu arby's
toujours en prise voici indies indeed
par bergerat peu cher round rock reggae
wacey dirty district dit dédé alias
cacau quartier crade déglingos mais pas
craignos les parigots ce à issy les
moulineaux
faire
aider
les capitaux
mais outre les neuf
moralité
[Musique]
m
à
oh
[Musique]
ils sont 2 3 ils sont combien cette
s'appelle comment ça s'appelle
complètement la légende du cornichon et
du jambon beurre sur leurs 33 la farce
ça s'appelle point la farce des points
de poitiers
je n'ai jamais coupé
mon ordination
manger un jour qu'on peut ap
[Musique]
une des histoires d'horreur
j'aurais voulu
je ne vais pas
enfin
plus encore
bon
oh
[Musique]
une baisse entre les commissions
la commission en
m
cette édition il à faire passer
je
californien féminin les arbres
d'essences et au gibus qu'ils descendent
fontonne blue ni satanique ni
sexologique hard esthétique premier
album première tournée date unique au
gibus bergère bonus
g
tous qu'on frise c'était une ville
toujours des mots voici guillemant les
lunettes de la semaine
j'ai dany bardy qui pose pour ce héros
ça s'arrose qu'elles vont au comptoir de
l'affiché bientôt bouquet de chansons et
c'est le divin l'enfant enfin en pièces
détachées à la michodière avec calfan et
chazel le painter vainqueur du prix de
la fondation jules verne c'est charles
louis de la salle mais pourquoi riz tuba
l'inconnu je sais plus à six parce que
je suis la blonde joconde de la semaine
vers +0 égale la tête à graphito du lp
de speedy c'était la partie mercredi au
palace classe et toutes les missions
tonnes la chanson joyeuse anniversaire
nos voeux les plus sincères le 25 branle
bas de combat pour barma il voici
compile les rolling stones spécial
période brian jones
l'astag l'un des trois premiers numéros
1 des glimmer twins cover franz par
ronnie bird parti lui aussi mais encore
plus loin au centre brian
ça va
mais
gb
à
[Musique]
c'est
1965 trois ans avant mai 68
insatisfaction d'une génération
premières puces bottes et riffs du
siècle
oh
à toi
m
je
et
oui
l'unité de black brian jones à son
apogée mais le sexe drogue et
rock'n'roll aura bientôt raison de
l'idole haïti malgré tout
en tt
pas que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais m
non
intermat premier album entièrement
cosigné jeger richard un an plus tard
c'est la taule et brian hâle hospital
personne
à
non
horreur de lit enfin les années ce kon
le philip norman édition énergie c'était
confie de spécial vite brian + juliette
binoche
patrick bruel
hubert selby
jean pierre dreno et dolphy ça faisait
lunettes noires pour nuits blanches
l'art du show du samedi soir bonsoir
salut burgenland
[Musique]
mais nice
mayroy justin
non
oui moi
là
bah
et toi
pour l'aïe
wade
m
[Musique]
mais au rap
non
oui moi
bah
coutras
pour les hommes
oh
[Musique]
aïe
oh
oui et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
nos latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu